le chanteur enrico macias justement pris
dans la tourmente du proche orient
son concert prévu demain à roubaix
provoque des remous
un collectif d'organisations favorables
aux palestiniens a demandé son
boycottage et prévoit de manifester
l' affaire prend une tournure politique
claire perdre et il est juif chante en
arabe et s'est toujours présenté comme
un ambassadeur de la paix pourtant
aujourd'hui sa musique crée la polémique
un collectif d'associations
pro-palestiniennes reproche à enrico
macias de soutenir israël dans le
conflit du proche orient
un tract appel au boycott du concert
prévu demain après midi à roubaix
l'organisatrice de la soirée a même reçu
des menaces
la meilleure réponse c'est que les gens
viennent au concert parce qu'on ne peut
pas empêcher non plus un artiste de
s'exprimer à cause de ses origines parce
que c'est aussi ce dont il a été
question en tout cas dans la lettre que
j'ai reçue il était question uniquement
de ça et je crois que des paroles de
paix ferait du bien tout le monde mes
chansons et importé quelque chose mais
de temps en temps elle dérange
quelques personnes mais finalement c'est
la musique qui gagne comme de nombreuses
associations ou partis politiques le
gouvernement français a exprimé son
soutien au chanteur qu'en tant que
ministre de la culture je suis
non seulement inquiète révulsé mais
profondément attristé que ça puisse de
viser un artiste ce qu'il fait sa parole
on ne doit pas servir danger à des
luttes qui en plus sur le faux sont
absolument inacceptables
déterminés les militants
pro-palestiniens manifesteront devant le
colisée
juste avant le début du concert enrico
macias ne veut pas céder au chantage
demain à roubaix il chantera la paix
mais sous haute protection policière